- You look, this is, oh!
- This is all -
- [Kelly] This is my childhood.
- Everyone who worked on this show,
your wardrobe team got this together
with a day or two notice.
They're amazing.
- You know why?
(audience clapping)
- They're amazing, yes!
- If you don't know this-
We're dressing for the eighties today.
And this is literally
top three characters of all time for me.
Especially for my childhood.
"Labyrinth's" David Bowie.
It was amazing.
(audience clapping)
- They mentioned that this
is your favorite movie.
Well, first of all, this is how I dress
- First of all. (laughs)
- I was like, "What's 'Labyrinth'?"
This is me.
(Kelly laughs)
- It's just a Monday.
- It's really all about the eyebrows.
- It's the pointy eyebrows.
- [Kelly] It's amazing.
I mean, you're about to just break out
and babe with the power,
it's gonna be amazing.
Did you love the movie as well?
- I did.
I remember the first time I saw it
and I was titillated and disturbed.
- Cause it's like, with
Toby, they're kind of scary.
A lot of it, it's very scary.
- They're horrifying.
It's what I love about Henson.
Henson doesn't talk down,
never talk down to kids.
They always assume the best of children
even when they're making terrifying stuff.
- Yeah!
And so I was terrified.
And then you see David Bowie in that movie
and I was a kid and I was
like, "What am I feeling here?
I'm feeling something."
- What was he feeling there?
Because his pants were tight!
- Do we think that was him
or was that like a cup?
We'll talk about it.
- I'm just saying, for
a child, you were like
it looks like a wrestler.
It looked like a lot happening down there.
- It definitely confused me.
I looked at that big bulge and I was like,
"Wait, what is the male anatomy then?"
- Why don't I have that?
- Is it one circle?
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] It was amazing.